I think sometimes people fear fear
starting a company too much you know to
say really what's the worst that could
go wrong you know kind of stuff to death
you know you're not gonna die of
exposure you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people
you cannot invent and pioneer if you
cannot accept failure wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well you are a genius so today let's
live your best believed life and learn
some of the best lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one don't fear fear too much with
Elon Musk
what motivations that people need to
harness to try to make change as opposed
to just reading about change that's not
supposed to be an easy question oh it's
it's this well like I said I think if
you if you study engineering and you
figure out how to design new things then
it's relatively easy to start a company
you just need to get a few like-minded
people with you and and then focus on
creating a prototype the compelling
prototype as soon as possible and then
that you know there's there's a strong
venture capital industry in this in this
country that will give you funding to
take things to the next level and that
that's all there's to it and you might
you know try it a few times might may or
may not succeed but I think sometimes
people fear fear starting a company too
much you know they have to say really
what's the worst that could go wrong you
know cast off to death you know
gonna die of exposure what's worse they
could go wrong lesson number two fill
your cup with Oprah Winfrey if I leave
you with nothing else it's just know
this for sure there is not one thing
that has ever happened to you
not one experience about one encounter
not one crisis not one joyful thing that
hasn't happened just to make you better
and help you rise every single thing
you're calling in whether you know it or
not when you figure out that you are
calling it in when you actually start
meditating or praying or doing or having
a spiritual practice which is the number
one thing you need if you want to be
successful in the world you need
something that gives back and nourishes
you regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up you end up tired
exhausted and don't have enough to give
to other people you end up resentful
every time somebody asked you because
your cup is empty and now they want some
of yours so your number one job your
number one job is to fill your cup and
make yourself whole that's your job
lesson number three do what you love
with Warren Buffett I was wondering how
you define success personally well I can
certainly define happiness because
that's what that's what I am I mean I I
and if that
I mean I get to do what I like to do
every single day of the year I get to do
it with people I like I get that I get
to I don't have to associate what
anybody causes my stomach to churn and
the only thing in my job I don't like
and it's only happens about every three
or four years a case you may have to
fire somebody and I don't like that's
the only thing other than I tap dance to
work and I get down there and I think
I'm supposed to lie on my back and paint
the ceiling you know or something I mean
yeah that's where I feel and I and it
doesn't diminish its it's tremendous fun
so you know if they say that success is
getting what you want and happiness is
wanting what you get well I don't know
which one applies in this case but I I
do know that I wouldn't be doing
anything else something that I do advise
you you know and when you go out to work
go to work for an organization that you
admire people you admire because it'll
it'll it'll turn you on and and and you
ought to be happy where you are working
and I always worry about people who say
you know I'm going to do this for ten
years I really don't like it very well
I'll be 10 more years he doesn't present
I mean that's a little like saving up
sex for your old age I mean
not a very good idea so get right it
recommend that get right into what you
enjoy you know and
and you'll be successful at it really
well I mean you won't be able to miss
and you know that's I don't regard what
I do is the most important thing in the
world at all but it's right for me I
mean I happen to be wired in a certain
way that what I do works in this if I
had to do what you know bill does I mean
last about 10 minutes and that's true of
a lot of things but I luckily I kind of
stumbled into the thing that I I do best
and that you know that it's worked out
boom also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series it's
free the link to join are in the
description below there are times when
if something is important enough you've
leave it enough that you do you do it in
spite of fear become so skilled so
vigilant so flat-out fantastic at what
you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed when I was selling copiers
door-to-door I had a very clear vision
of what my life was gonna be like lesson
number four experiment more with Jeff
Bezos you cannot invent and pioneer if
you cannot accept failure its you to
invent you need to experiment and if
it's if you know in advance that it's
going to work it is not an experiment
and so that's a very important thing you
know it's these they're inseparable
twins failure and invention it's so you
have to be willing to do that it's
embarrassing to fail you know it's
always embarrassing to fail but you have
to say no that's not how this works if I
said to you you have a 10% chance of a
with a particular decision a 10% chance
of a 100x return you should take that
bet every time but you're still gonna be
wrong nine out of ten times and it's
gonna feel bad nine out of ten times and
in in in with technology the outcomes
the results can be very long tailed they
it's very the payoff is can be very
asymmetric which is why you should do so
much experimentation you know everybody
knows that if you swing for the fences
you hit more home runs which should also
strike out more
but with the baseball that analogy
doesn't go far enough because with
baseball no matter how well you connect
with the ball you can only get four runs
the success is capped at four runs but
in business every once in a while you
step up to the plate you hit the ball so
hard you get a thousand runs and so when
that when you have that kind of
asymmetric payoff and you know one app
one app back and get you a thousand runs
it encourages you to experiment more
it's the right business decision to
experiment more it's also better for
your customers customers like the
successful experiments listen number
five get used to being challenged with
Jack Ma people like us we are getting
used to be criticized we're getting used
to be said no people say no to you when
people say yes to you we're really
appreciate because it's not you know why
people should say yes to you you have to
prove so as the ancient premier you have
to get used to be challenged have to get
used to be said no by the other people
by the fact by the investors by your
customers by the people but this this is
the opportunity when everybody believe
it you have no chance we're only a few
people believe it you believe it you
prove it that's your chance lesson
number six be courageous with Sara
Blakely my dream is for there to be many
more female inventors I'm hoping more
more and more women will have the
courage to take that risk it's a risk to
invent something you have to risk being
made fun of you have to risk looking
like an idiot you have to do something
that didn't already exist which is scary
I mean my brain told me a million times
who do you think you are coming up with
this and then
one day you wake up and you go well what
if it is me and lesson number seven the
last one before very special bonus clip
is learned from history with Mark Cuban
one of the things that companies do or
startups do they come up with an idea
they'll google it and if they don't see
it in the first two pages they think
it's original you got to go back right
because over the past 15 years there's
so many different businesses that have
tried and failed you have to go back and
find those and learn from those so
you've got to understand all the
implications and you have to learn from
history and so the best advice I can
give you on a video before talking to
you or emailing with you is that you've
got to find out the history of people
who have tried your idea because there's
a 99.99999% chance that your idea has
been tried before that's not a good
reason not to start it because you might
be able to outperform them but you
better learn from the history of your
idea um because you know what they say
about people who don't learn from
history now I have a special bonus clip
from Mark Zuckerberg on how to build a
good team that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what is the fear that you are fearing
too much number two what's the
courageous action that you need to take
this week and number three how will you
fill your cup today and if you like this
video and you're going to take some
action after watching it give me a
hashtag belive down the comments as well
companies are not about any one person
right it's really not about any two
people either they're they're these
combinations of people and teams and I
think the ones that that work best are
when you have people who have different
strengths who complement each other and
I think a huge part of the success of
Facebook and our ability to grow the
community has been because of the
partnership that we've built and and a
number of other really special people
here who are on the the core group who
just each have different skills and are
very different and are not afraid to to
challenge each other and bring their
voice to the table and I think that
that's a special thing
if you want some more lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
remember if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories